i apologize can we move on i feel like
her apology
was you know
as genuine as when she shushed you
you're 22. i killed it enough it said a
lot
i have an issue with the idea of
entitlement versus character
well said it's all been tragically
consistent
i'll just say that the parents of 14
year old keon harold jr who was falsely
accused of taking 22 year old mia
poncetto's phone at a hotel in new york
city
are speaking out following mia's bizarre
interview with cbs this morning
yeah i apologize can we move on
those were the exact words that she used
with you does that sound like an apology
she knew she assaulted a 14 year old boy
not a guy not a man let me get you up to
speed
on december 26th poncetto was seen on
security cameras approaching a black
teenager and his dad
jazz musician keon harold in the lobby
of nyc's arlo hotel
are you kidding me you feel like there's
only one one iphone made in the world no
okay then show me this no
you get to get a life over there what's
on your background
poncetto falsely accused the 14 year old
boy keon harold jr
of stealing her phone ultimately
tackling him in an attempt to get the
phone back
let me note her missing phone was later
found
at the hotel harold captured the alleged
assault in a one-minute video
posted to his instagram and the whole
thing was also documented on the hotel's
surveillance camera
no i'm not letting him walk away with my
phone
the clip went viral poncetto was dubbed
the soho karen online
and last week she sat down with gayle
king and her attorney for a virtual
interview
just hours before she was arrested in
california by the new york city police
department
basically i'm i'm a 22 year old girl
i am i i don't i racism
uh is i said i how is one girl
accusing a guy
about a phone a crime
you're 22 years old but you are old
enough to know better so i will say
you're 22. i
killed it enough the hotel did have my
phone
the hotel did end up having my phone on
monday harold who claims his son was the
victim of racial profiling
and his son's mother kat rodriguez got
emotional
talking about the whole thing with cbs
this morning this young lady
blindsided him in the hotel he keeps on
asking the question
why like why me mom you know i wouldn't
steal anything
i didn't know her why
as a mother to have to answer that
question
and on monday the network aired more of
ponsetto's interview
it didn't seem as if uh my accusations
really bothered the
the son and the father because they were
just uh enjoying a nice meal right after
this whole uh encounter but all i'm
saying i don't know if you
mean i don't want to be over and i'm
sorry
yeah she gave gail sass over you're 22.
i
killed it enough and over again when you
looked at that video
what did you think what did you think
mia you already asked me that video you
already asked me that in the beginning
of the interview
i'm not i'm not going over it again i i
would like to
i would like to have a real interview
with real questions and real heart and
real
sincere apologies let 2021 be the moment
of healing
seriously last week when e.t asked her
attorney sharon h guitar about the sit
down
guitar explained quote i started to
question her well-being and i am
genuinely concerned for her mental
health at this point
i told her to stop i was adamant i was
stern
and she was making me feel uncomfortable
and everyone else feel uncomfortable
and it was enough